[Music]
Again, we greet you in Jesus name and
bid you hello to our friends and members
of the extended SumTV family. So good to
have you here for I'd like to know our
Bible question and answer program. My
name is CA Murray and I have to my right
pastor Steven Bore, our founder and
president of the ministry. pastor,
always good to have you here. It's a
blessing to work with you, CA. And
Pastor David Salazar to my left, who
superintends our Latino work and does a
very, very fine job there in. Pastor,
always good to have you here. Thank you,
pastor. It's an honor to be with you. As
we always say, this is our Bible
question and answer program. We want to
just let you know that you can join in
on the fun if you will write us at
tvsumtv.org. That is
tvsumtv.org. and we will get to your
questions just as quickly as we possibly
can. But before we go into today's show,
we've got some great news to give to
you. As many of you know, the general
conference session is coming up very,
very soon. It begins July 3rd and
continues to July 12th. We will have a
booth there. It is booth
107. It's off in the corner just a
little bit, but we've got a big sign
that's going to be up top. So, if you
can't find us, just scan the roof and
you will see our sign there. The reason
we're giving you this information is
because we would like you to be part of
our broadcast
experience. We answer your questions
here on on I'd like to know. We'd like
you to come and deliver your Bible
questions in person. We'll put a camera
there. You'll ask your questions and
then we'll answer them during the
program. You can stay for the program or
you can answer your question and do
something else. We'll get to your
question and we'll answer them on the
program. Now, just as a little
inducement to help you, to encourage
you, uh I am told by the production
staff here that we've got a little gift
for you. If you will come by, ask your
question on camera, be part of this
experience. We've got a little way to
say thank you. They haven't told me what
it is. Uh we'd like to get one, but I
don't know if we're eligible, but you
can get one just as soon as you ask your
question on camera, and then we'll do
that together. We're also going to be
doing Sabbath school in English and
Spanish. So, we've got a lot of things
happening at the booth number 107. We
want you to be part of that. So, you
make a date to join us. That's July 3
through July
12. Booth 107, SumTV, Secrets Unsealed.
I'd like to know. Thank you so very much
in advance. Pastor Boore, would you pray
for us, please? Sure. And we'll begin.
Father in heaven, we come before you
with
humility, but at the same time, we come
boldly because we come in the name of
Jesus. We ask that you will bless us in
this program, that the answers that we
provide will be in harmony with your
holy word. We ask that you will bless
all of those who watch and listen to
this program that the desires of their
heart might be met and that the answers
might be absolutely clear and helpful to
their spiritual walk with the Lord. This
we pray in the precious and holy name of
Jesus. Amen. Amen. Amen. Amen. Amen. You
know, my sister called me the other day.
She watches this program, dare I say,
religiously. She likes the idea that we
don't rush through the questions. Uh
I've heard some people say well you take
so much time but we we think if you are
going to take the time to ask the
questions we should take the sufficient
amount of time to answer the questions
and not rush to through or give answers
sort of off the top of our heads. We
like to do a little study and that's
what we think uh hallmarks this
particular program. We like to study and
get the answer to you from the word of
god. So there comes a question now from
empu. Uh, I hope I find you well. I'd
like to know what is Ellen White uh and
our church's stand on prescribed
medication. Is it wrong to use them or
not as a nurse? Am I in the wrong
profession? Thank you in advance. Um,
looking at this from the back, isn't
Jalisa a nurse? Your wife is a nurse?
Yes, she is. My sister is a nurse. Yes.
and my mother worked in X-ray department
all of our years in at the hospital. So,
we've got a lot of nursing type people
around. So, if it's wrong, we're in
trouble. It is not wrong to be to be a
nurse. I'll tell you a quick story and
I'm sorry I'm taking time here. Charles
Bradford, you know who Charles Bradford
was? Absolutely. Great leader of the
church. Uh in talking with him, he he
told me one day his mother was uh the
nurse for Ellen White when she was in in
uh New England. his mother was was her
nurse. And he was telling how uh his
mother began to change her ways because
now uh Ellen White was a New Englander.
Charles Bradford was from I think
Oklahoma or or or Arkansas, one of
those. And so she began to to you know
adopt Ellen White's pulling her hair
back and putting in a bun and wearing
the black dress with the little white
collar. And one day Ellen White sat her
down and said, "Listen, don't be like
me. I'm I'm not your example. Jesus is
your example. So don't try to be like
me. just be like Jesus. But she was
Ellen White's nurse. So nursing can't be
wrong because Ellen White had several
during her lifetime. Right. Yeah. And
the Lord not only, you know, um, used
her to to have the instructions for our
church, but instructed her specifically
to develop or to push the development of
health facilities, hospitals,
sanitariums, wellness centers, and the
need for uh nurses, doctors or or even
medical missionaries was something that
she extensively wrote about. So it's one
of the careers that you are definitely
uh called to do in this time to become
actively in helping in restoring the
health of those who are less fortunate
than are sick. So the the answer to the
question is he or she in the wrong prof
profession absolutely not. Now just like
in any profession any role there are
good excellent people and those that are
not so good. There are great pastors,
faithful followers of the Lord, but also
sadly not everyone who professes to be a
pastor of God is doing that faithful
job. So definitely also in in in the
medical field, physicians, there are
physicians who are doing the right
thing, helping people, treating people,
helping them with their health, whe with
sickness, with their illness. And there
are maybe some who are not doing that
and have used the system of prescription
to a degree of a business. So I I could
understand some of the things and my
wife being a nurse uh knows this very
well. So uh but I think that I want to
read briefly read because he asked or
she asked the question in regards to
what Ellen White's comments are and I
think that there are a few comments that
she mentions in regards to prescriptions
that perhaps is what may give the
impression that all prescriptions are
wrong and I'm going to read them and
then we'll explain limitly because we're
not doctors either so you know have that
in mind but I I'm going to read from um
this is council on health page page
261 and it says uh page I'm sorry 152
rather uh that says the following. A
practice that is laying the foundation
of a vast amount of disease and of even
more serious evils is the free use of
poisonous drugs. When attacked by
disease, many will not take the travel
to search out the cause of their
illness. Their chief anxiety is to rid
themselves of pain and
inconvenience. So here's the principle
that she's laying what is wrong. It says
by the use of poisonous drugs, many
bring upon themselves lifelong illness
and many lives are lost that might be
saved by the use of natural methods of
healing. The poisons containing in so
many culties create habits and appetites
that may that mean ruin to both soul and
body. Then she says, "Drug medication as
it's generally prescribed is a curse.
Educate away from drugs. Use them less
and less and depend more upon hygienic
agencies. Then nature will respond to
God's physicians. Pure air, pure water,
proper exercise, a clear conscience.
Those who persist in the use of tea,
coffee, flesh meats will feel in need of
drugs. But many might recover without
one grain of medicine if they will obey
the laws of health. drugs need seldom be
used. So this is again when she was in
her experience and many of those drugs
that were available were poisonous as
she clearly mentions and she's making an
emphasis that the main problem is when
people want to alleviate the symptom and
the pain and not really change their
habit change with the problem. Maybe
what caused brought them to that
situation is their wrong habits of lack
of hygiene, lack of eating well, lack of
exercise, lack of pure air, etc. So the
the argument that she's making is it's
very balanced. It's not she's not saying
drugs are completely off the table,
never should be used. Uh again, drugs
have really become much more advanced as
time has gone by. People have been
receiving a lot of wisdom in that the
scientists have been very wise in in
improving certain things but the
principles remain the same. We need to
help people to change their habits to be
in harmony with God. And there are
individuals who need uh prescriptions
because of their condition, maybe their
heart, maybe their uh you know their own
illness. But as long as they want to
follow the Lord's and their proper laws
of health that God will help them and
help them recover and again let the
physician a godly physician dictate and
help you achieve that fullness of life
that God wants you to have. You know the
problem is we live in a society that
wants immediate gratification. True. You
know if I have a headache why not take
an aspirin? I mean that right away. But
it takes care of the symptom, but it
doesn't take care of the reason for the
headache. Yeah. And and healing takes
time. Yeah. And and it it takes living
in a harmony with the laws of health. In
other words, we need to strengthen our
immune system by following the eight
laws of health that are mentioned in the
spirit of prophecy. Proper diet,
exercise, good water, good fresh clean
water. Yeah. Uh, you know,
sunshine, all of these are are natural
remedies. Uh, and Ellen White constantly
emphasizes that that that is the way to
keep us strong and uh to heal disease.
But it takes time and the trouble is
people don't want to uh wait. They want
immediate gratification. Uh so uh there
are remedies that are very effective,
natural remedies. I remember I had an
experience when I was in Colombia
teaching theology at our university.
They invited all of the teachers from
Colombia to come to a class where we
studied the book education by Ellen
White. And as the class began, this
lasted for about two
weeks, terrible attack of diarrhea. You
know, down there you have uh problems
with amiebas. Yeah, amiebas. Right. and
I got a terrible and I took every
medication that you could get at the
pharmacy and man it didn't take care of
the issue and then I remember I me I met
Nelie Restreo who's who is a medical
doctor and I told her you know I'm
miserable and and she says oh you know
I've got something for you uh she said
charcoal activated charcoal there you go
and I thought to myself
really my my first introduction is
charcoal and and I took it and within
one day it was gone. Amen. That's a
natural remedy. Yeah. And uh I'm not
saying that every disease can be healed
with natural remedies. Yes. Sometimes
you know uh you have to take medication.
Yeah. But uh you have to make sure that
you ask the proper people what the
medication is going to do and whether it
is going to cause more damage than good.
I'm sorry. No pastor. Go ahead. Dr.
James Markhamm. He's an Adventist
cardiologist. I I don't think you can do
better than a competent doctor who knows
the Lord and praise the Lord. That's
that's the best of both worlds. But he's
written a book. I don't remember the
name of the book, but it deals with uh
the toxic effect of some modern
medications. Um there are some things
that do you good in the short term, but
the long-term effects are, you know,
sometimes you hear these commercials on
TV and they'll say this will uh do this,
but you may have thoughts of suicide.
you may want to cut off your arm, you
know, and the list of of of things they
give you is is is 2 minutes long,
probably 20 or 30. You better just have
the disease than than the side effects,
you know. So, all of these things that
are good. But James Markham's book does
deal with some of the the long-term
effects of certain medications that and
you have to weigh the balance, you know,
is it help me now? Is it going to hurt
me later? Kind of thing. But, uh, you
you need to trust the Lord. Pastor
David, no I was just going to add pastor
and I think it's important to what you
were saying there is again the need all
of us have gone through sickness and
illness and no one likes to be sick or
have to you know seek attention or need
uh but our friend here who is a nurse
asked a question should I change my
profession he the answer is no he should
continue or she should continue to be a
nurse that's one of the most beautiful
professions you have as a as a human
being to help and and aid someone. I I
believe that what this individual needs
to ask is ask the Lord to
help in in their profession to teach
people how not only to alleviate the
pain, the momentary agony or whatever,
but to truly help them to realize that
health is a process that God wants to
give to an individual as they're willing
to submit to the necessary laws of
health that the Lord has established for
their bodies. that you mentioned the
eight laws of health that we all know
you know the water air sunlight exercise
rest uh uh nutrition rest trusting god
and uh sunlight and all these things
that are necessary these are things that
will definitely be there and are
available for free but as we teach them
we might have to give them certain you
know prescriptions but help them to
truly go to the way that God wants them
to live not just to alleviate or pate
the problem but to truly help them to
guide them to the knowledge of God and
how he wants our bodies to be cared for.
Amen. Amen. Amen. Thank you so very much
for the question and we hope that we
have uh answered it sufficiently uh to
the glory of God and to your liking. We
move now to South Africa. Uh a question
num from Michael. Um Michael here from
South Africa. I'm struggling with not
only fully committing myself to God, but
also following him. Well, they go one
with the other. You know, you don't
commit, it's hard to follow. I've grown
up in the SJA church, but only recently
have started to really want to follow
God and visiting church more often. I'm
also in the process of being baptized.
I'm finding it hard and I keep getting
distracted by worldly things. I'm also
very stressed out over the end times,
Sunday law, second coming of Christ. I'm
worried about not receiving everlasting
life. It is my greatest wish to be
saved. How do I depend on Jesus to be
saved and not on my own ambitions? How
do I really have a relationship with him
is his question. I think this comes from
a s a sincere place and it probably
echoes the sentiments of many people who
know what is right, want to do what is
right, but lack the focus and the
resolve uh and the surrender to do what
is right. So how do we help them out? A
strong relationship with someone is
built by spending time with that
person. You can't have a strong
relationship with someone unless you
spend time with them. Um I would ask
this
individual, what are your um habits when
it comes to what you watch and what you
hear? Agent times I have young people
come and they ask me, they say, "Pastor
Boore, you know, I have these specific
sins that I can't uh overcome and my
first question is what are you watching
and what are you listening to?" Mhm. And
usually they'll, you know, look down and
they know that they have been watching
and listening to things, you know, music
and movies and things like that. You can
never expect to have a strong
relationship with Christ unless you u
behold Christ. Amen. On a regular basis.
You know, the Apostle Paul gave us a
secret. I mean, it's not the best kept
secret in the world. Uh in 2 Corinthians
chapter 3 and verse 18, the Apostle Paul
gives us the secret. And some people
say, well, you know, that's absolutely
too simple. It's, you know, the simple
things uh usually work better than the
complex things. Amen. Um it says there
in uh 2 Corinthians chapter 3 and:e 18
um but we all with unveiled face
beholding as in a mirror the glory of
the Lord that's the character of the
Lord are being transformed into the same
image from glory to glory just as by the
spirit of the lord. So the bottom line
is by what be we behold we have changed.
Amen. If we're spending time with
Christ. Yeah. You know Ellen White says
a thoughtful hour each day contemplating
especially the closing scenes. Yeah.
Start there in the gospels. And you know
you hear Jesus in Gethsemane crying out
to his
father. If this cup can pass from me let
it be so. Nevertheless, not my will be
done, but yours. And he's sweating drops
of blood while he's crying out three
times in the garden. You know, you ask
the question, Jesus, why did this happen
to you? He's going to say, because of
your sins. Yeah. And then I hear him on
the cross crying out, my God, my God,
why have you forsaken me? Because he
didn't feel that the father was there
because he was bearing the load of sin,
including mine. Amen. And and you know,
I say, Jesus, why did this happen to
you? And he says, "Because of your sins,
then I'm going to come to love the
Savior and I'm going to hate the sin for
what the sin did to the Savior." Right?
You know, we don't overcome sin by
fighting sin. We overcome sin by
beholding the Savior. That's that's and
because people many times are just going
through a list. They're saying, "Am I
doing this? Am I doing this? Am I not
doing this? Am I not doing that?" You
know, that would be taken care of. Yeah.
If you're just beholding Christ on a
regular basis, your relationship will
grow and as Paul says, you will be
transformed from glory to glory. Your
character will improve every day and uh
everything will change.
It's interesting to see pastor you know
how in the Bible we have the the largest
book of the Bible is the book of Psalms
and is the book of prayers. Prayer is
the beginning experience of any
individual who wants to have victory.
And prayer needs to be one where you
open your heart to the Lord truly and
say, "Lord, you know, I'm not going to
come to you imposing or acting like I'm
holy or good. I am need I am in need of
you." And that humility, that
humbleness, the desire to be, like you
said, to be transformed, to change, to
to behold the Lord will give you the
necessary desire to forsake sin. Looking
at Christ, you gain the victory and you
can continue that process. our our our
our prayer our prayer life should be one
that reflects that necess necessity of
the heart of the of our of our heart of
our inward desire of our mind to truly
be like Christ. And so you know I would
suggest you know to to this young man to
to really spend time in prayer study the
scriptures as you were mentioned that is
the starting point and the key to keep a
life of victory. reject that or or
turning 12 to autopilot if you will, you
know, going from Sabbath to Sabbath to
church, then you'll become
completely and un unable to become or to
have the desire to do the will of God
and therefore you're going to fall. You
know, when when you look at the
question, uh this person seems to be
particularly stressed out. Yes. By
what's going to happen in the end times.
Yes. You mentioned Sunday law, the
second coming of Christ. I'm worried
about not receiving everlasting life. Uh
it's my greatest wish to be saved. Uh
you know, how is this problem resolved?
Well, it's very simple. It's by
beholding Christ and falling in love
with Christ. Amen. The question is,
amen.
Is your focus, oh, I don't want to lose
out on eternal life. Or is your focus, I
want to spend eternity with Christ. And
uh and so you know the Bible says that
perfect love casts out fear. Amen.
Perfect love for God and for Christ
casts out fear. And in order for your
love to grow, you have to know the
person. And you know the person through
the study of scripture. Amen. Amen.
Amen. I I think there's a very nuance
and and that's a very nuance answer that
you gave. You know, you seek first the
kingdom and then these other things tend
to resolve themselves, right? Because
they are overshadowed by your love for
Christ. It is a mistake to believe that
we're going to make it into heaven
without some stern battles being fought
with ourselves. You know, Illinois tells
us, and I was looking for the quote, I
just I just couldn't find it, that the
longer you engage in a habit, the
stronger the hold that habit has on you.
Mhm. And so to disengage will not be a
matter of occasional prayer or just
feeling bad about it. You've got to you
got to lock down on on the Lord. You've
got to fight battles with yourself. So
don't think it will be easy, but know
that it is possible. Amen. That which we
feed lives. That which we starve which
we which we starve dies. Salvation is
not avoidance theology. It's replacement
theology. You throw out the old old and
replace it with the new. It's not your
job to go around it. You got to hit it
and meet it sometimes. But as you toss
out old stuff, you replace it with new
stuff uh and and you draw closer to
Christ. And you find as you well in
tone, pastor, as you draw closer to
Christ, some of these things tend to
resolve themselves and sort of fall off
you like scales. You know they do
because you're in a new place. You got a
new heart. You got a new mind. And those
things that you used to love that you
didn't think you could live without, now
you know you can through Jesus Christ.
And so, uh, Michael, we hope this has
been of of of assistance to you. Many
have fought this battle. In fact,
everybody that's going to heaven has had
to fight this battle one way or another.
But we know that success is is available
to us through Jesus Christ. We can and
will be overcomers. Again, thank you for
joining us today. Our time has slipped
into eternity. Allow me in closing to
wish you both grace and peace through
our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ. We'll
see us in s again soon. Bye-bye and God
bless.
[Music]